welcome back almost done we're on
problem number 19 let me read it out
loud at a body at a bottling company
machine a fills a bottle with spring
water and machine B accepts the bottle
only if the fluid ounces is between
eleven seven eight and twelve and one
eighths so let me let me say oh four
ounces so the ounces have to be between
eleven and seven eighths this is and
that's oh not zero maybe I'll use X X 4
ounces x four ounces that's an X that
weird-looking symbol and twelve and 1/8
that's what B accepts if if the ounces
are between that if B accepts a bottle
containing n fluid ounces which of the
following describes all possible values
of n so they're actually saying n four
ounces we could just say this so n is
between these two terms and they give a
bunch of choices that involve absolute
values right and and what I'm gonna do
is actually I'm gonna draw this on a
number line and then I think you're
gonna the absolute values are gonna make
sense let me do a another color just to
change things a little bit so if this is
the number line this is the number line
and this is o and this is 11 and 7/8 11
and 7 8 11 and 7/8 and this is 12 and 1
eighths right an an has to be between
these two numbers right and could can be
anything between these two numbers so
what when they're doing absolute value I
guess you can see that you know they're
saying that they have all these twelves
and all that and I think you could
immediately see the 12 is right in the
middle of these of these two numbers
right 12 is right there in the middle
let me do a different card this is 12
right it's right smack dab in the middle
and as long as n is
is a little bit less than 12 or a little
bit more than 12 we're okay the Machine
B is going to accept it right so how
much how much more how much more than 12
can can n B right this is n n can be
anywhere in this range it obviously if
we're if n is 12
it's like perfect it's just like right
in the middle it's definitely nowhere
close to one of the the the bad outs is
it's kind of the perfect ounce perfect
number of ounces in the bottle on the
spring water let's see so how much more
can can it can be one eighths more right
this distance is 1/8 how much more can n
be than twelve it can be one eighths
more and how much less well this
distance is also 1/8 right so we know
that n minus twelve right the difference
between N and twelve the difference
between N and twelve and we don't know
if n is greater than 12 or n is less
than twelve so we'll say just the
difference and we're gonna take the
absolute value so because if n is
greater the absolute value doesn't
matter right and if n is less then we'll
get a you know n minus 12 will be a
negative number but we just care about
kind of the the absolute difference we
don't care whether you know one is
negative or one is positive so we say
that n minus 12 has to be less the
difference between N and 12 and that's
just the absolute value of n minus 12
has to be less than or equal to this
kind of tolerance right if you you
probably have done much manufacturing
yet but if you do this this is kind of
thing you'll deal with so that's to be
less than or equal to 1/8 and I want you
to play around with this I mean we could
you could say well and can't be more
than 1/8 more than 12 so you could say
that n minus 12 is has to be less than
or equal to 1/8 and then you could also
say that on this side n minus 12 right
if n is around here n minus 12 so this
is this is if n is greater than 12 is n
is greater than 12 and then if n is less
than 12 then n minus 12 has to be
greater than or equal to minus 1/8 right
this might be more confusing to you and
I'm debating whether I should even write
it but these two things would also
translate into this but the big picture
absolute value just means the difference
between two numbers I don't care if one
is bigger than the other I'm just saying
that the difference between these two
numbers cannot be more than 1/8 so n
minus 12 the absolute value is less than
or equal to 1/8 and this choice
well actually it's between these two
violins it can't equal these values so
that can't equal these values so it's
not less than or equal so it's not less
than equals just less than n minus 12 is
less than 1/8 that's choice C and we are
on the last problem in the clear image
invert colors number 20 almost there
the in the least integer of a set of
consecutive integers is minus 25 so the
least the smallest is equal to minus 25
the least is minus 25 if the sum of
these integers is 26 so the sum is equal
to 26 how many integers are in this set
this is interesting so I have like I
have minus 25 plus something plus
something plus something and when I add
up all of the integers if I add up all
of the integers I get 26 right so this
is so the least integer of a set of
consecutive integers is minus 25 if the
sum of these integers is 26 how many
integers are in this set well we start
with minus 25 right so the rest of the
integers the rest of the integers are
gonna have to equal what if you know
this is an equation right minus 25 plus
all of these random things so let's add
25 2 to both sides of these things so
the rest of the integers are gonna have
to equal so you know dot you know let's
call it
is I to because this is I won right
enters your three interger four plus
integer n right because then we don't
know how many there are so that means
that I 2 plus I 3 + bump up up up up we
don't know a bunch I and it's gonna
equal I'm just adding 25 to both sides
of this equation so that is equal to 51
right so how you see the least integer
of a set of consecutive integers is
minus 25 oh I forgot that's consecutive
integers so we'd actually know what
these values are consecutive right so I
2 is gonna be minus 24 I actually did
this I you can almost ignore what I said
just now let me actually clear this I
didn't read that consecutive it's
important to read your problems properly
so it's minus 25 minus 24 plus minus 24
plus minus 23 is all and then you know
we don't know how high it goes but that
is equal to 26 right so what do we know
we know that like when we go from minus
25 minus 25 plus minus 24 plus you know
minus 23 all right and we're gonna go
all the way to 0 and then we're gonna
keep adding that to you know 1 plus 2
Plus 3 plus 4 and we're gonna add you
know so you know well let me let me
write it this way minus 25 plus minus 24
plus minus 23 Plus mMmmm you know plus
plus minus 1 plus 0 plus 1 plus 2 plus
you know 24 plus 25 so I claim that the
sum of all the integers from - 25 to 25
is going to be 0 and how do I know that
well because minus 1 let me switch
colors
- one's gonna cancel out with one you
know minus two is going to can
a lot with two -23 is gonna cancel it
with positive 23-24 is gonna cancel out
with 24 and 25 is gonna cancel out with
26 25 second cancel out negative 25 is
gonna cancel out with positive 25 and so
the last term 26 has nothing to cancel
out with it and that's the sum right
because all of the other terms cancelled
out so how many terms are there so to go
from minus 25 to minus 1 that is 25
terms then to go from 1 to 25 that's 25
terms and then we have 0 is 1 term and
then 26 is another term right so it's 25
plus 25 is 50 plus 1 plus 150 two terms
and that is choice E and we are done
that first section I hope you had fun
I'll see you soon